welcome to another installment of
beginner breakdown I am a Mike comer and
I'll be helping you today basically
today we're going to go over my two
favorite things
double pawns and a-holes all right so
here we go all right so you'll see a lot
of holes come out of a Sicilian defense
what a hole is is basically a place on
the board where you can put a piece and
no pawn can kick you out of there okay
so it's good to have make your opponents
have holes in their position and limit
your amount of holes okay so here we go
right in the Sicilian for white white
starts out efore black counters with c5
going into the Sicilian white plays
Knight f3 all standard stuff d6 d4 takes
takes Knight f6 attacks the pawn so
white the fence with Knight c3 black
plays a6 not allowing anybody into b5
very good white plays Bishop e3 and now
black voluntarily gives themself a hole
with the move e5 okay
well it's really cool to attack a piece
it's going to give yourself a long-term
weakness okay where this is a the hole
right on d5 okay so you shouldn't play
this for black okay does that make sense
even though Julian will say this is a
superstar Julian even though he'll say
oh this is a great great move
but now White has a black has given us
up a long term weakness and the d6 pawn
is now a backwards pawn well good luck
another way to play now this is also a
position that comes out of the Sicilian
efore c5 on move to white gives himself
a whole
with c4 okay all right so this is what
you need to do so this is the hole all
right so to see this square all right
so d4 so now if you ever see this
position you're playing black here's the
plan who who do you who do you want in
that whole night you want the night that
that's the idea you want the night in
that hole okay all right so so your idea
for move to win this game should be to
eliminate this bishop this bishop this
night this night for who do you think
who should you try to trade those three
pieces for and don't say Queen and two
rooks all right so who do you think no
all right so the wrong answers were said
many but the right answers are this
night this night and now the million
dollar question the dark square bishop
leaving yourself with this night against
this light square bishop and you can
never kick you out make sense all right
it should make sense to everybody okay
so as you'll see in this game coming up
how you can exploit the holes all right
all right so here's a game I played
against James Brown state last week you
remember I played his a son Doug and one
in a great end game this one I just
flat-out just win all right using the
holes all right so white comes out or
wait a minute
all right efore c5 I am playing white
white plays Knight f3 black plays d6
much like the other game but my idea is
I like to get castled as soon as
possible so if I want to get castle as
soon as possible what more do you think
i should play Bishop check good Bishop
check all right so now he counters
Bishop Bishop
so just take check and now by move four
I'm castled and pretty safe all right
so black plays Knight to c6 c3 an idea
and chest is that these Center ponds are
worth more than the wing pawns
all right so knowing that you would
never want to trade a center pawn for
our cyclone right so you would prepare
it with c3 makes sense to me all right
so black plays Knight f6 attacking my
pawn so so I played d4 now unfortunately
this point would be hanging so protect
it with rook e1 it's a natural square
for a rook that's where you like it all
right so Knight to e5 all right so I
love giving my opponents double pawns
but with this double pawns be good for
him or bad for him so if I took all
right
and he took back now he's got this
weakness these double pawns but can i
play d4 now without losing anything it's
legal it is a legal move so I could
technically play d4 but there would be
massive repercussions okay I would lose
up on and I love my material and now he
doesn't even have as double pawns
anymore to add insult to injury all
right so so even though I could give my
opponent double pawns it's not
necessarily go
good to take it just because you can
make sense all right so my plan was d4
so just go ahead with the plan so takes
with check so Queen takes you don't want
to you don't want to damage your castle
by taking and doubling your pawns
so now black comes out with e5 all right
so what did he just give himself by
playing a 500 thank you all right a hole
on this square again all right
d5 yeah yeah yeah I know yeah
oh so d5 hole all right so should I push
my pawn into the hole no all right so I
want to get my knight into that hole
some point all right make sense okay so
first things first I want to eliminate
this Knight right because he when I put
my knight in the hole he could just take
and then what's the point
all right so Bishop attacks now he makes
a big mistake here Queen to g4 all right
so now I see a chance to either win a
pawn or give himself give him double
points what I really want to do all
right
so how can I give him eventually double
points it might take two or three moves
to calculate it out all right you should
always be looking for forcing moves when
you're playing that's checks and
captures always be looking for those so
if I gave him so I could give them
double pawns right off the bat really so
I could take and you would not take back
here would not take back he would take
my guy I would take him he would take so
we both have double pawns that's no fun
all right I want to be the only one with
straight connected cool pawns all right
so so what move can I make
all right so Queen takes g4 so the night
takes o now how are you going to give
them double pawns he doesn't even eight
on f6 anymore right okay will force them
back okay so so h3 or f3 you might say
oh what's the difference well the
difference is we're in an endgame now so
you might as well play f3 that way your
King can come come out and become a
warrior okay f3 is okay if that was f6
forget about it but but f3 is cool
alright so f3 so now he's like are you
sure you don't want double pawns too so
he's offering the trade right Bishop
takes h6 would be a big mistake because
the knight could come back and get it
okay but it's something you should have
considered for like a half second
alright so where should I put my bishops
should I put my bishop back here
no alright because I want to get him
double pawn so I would play Bishop to h5
okay and now what's really interesting
if he plays g5 in this position right
that's what I would have played in the
game and it would have been a losing
move but but then I could I could just
retreat my Bishop to e3 and then if he
plays Knight f6 take the pawn take the
pawn Bishop takes pawn okay all right
and I'm lucky I'm lucky he did not play
this in the game cuz because if he would
have played g5 I would have instantly
taken that's why because I didn't
calculate I would have instantly taken
here pawn takes pawn takes and then he's
going to take that pawn right so it
would have been the worst but then he's
got this Bishop move that's pretty cool
so it's a little bit good but but now I
mean all my all my ideas of
finishing them what the holes are gone
so luckily the game didn't go that way
and the game basically went Bishop h5
did not play g5 he retreated so we took
right away pawn takes f6 so now we have
to deal with this situation he's got two
pawns attacking our pawn so should we
take this way or the other way
Knight to d2 yeah so so luckily we have
Peter Emmer in the class that's yelling
out the correct answer pawn takes e5
alright so now we know what to do he's
gave himself one hole and by doubling
his pawns he gave himself another hole
so we'll get our night to e3 and then
we'll have our choice of where to put
our night then so night to d2 Bishop e7
Knight 83 would have been fine too but
but I want to I want to give myself
options Knight to f1 by playing Knight
to a3 Knight to c4 yeah that's true
alright
rook to d8 alright so I have this plan
going where I want where I want to get
my knight here and then my knight up
here but he just played rook to d8 so he
is currently in control of the D file so
I'm going to put my plan on hold for a
minute and take over the D file here
okay because if I would play Knight to
e3 obviously he could play rook to d2
and get a lot of counter play rook there
there and I'm in a lot of trouble okay
so makes sense to me all right rook to
d1 castles it connects his rooks
all right so now I would never want to
trade this rook for here because because
it's a bad move yeah
and then now he would have the file and
I'd be in a lot of trouble all right so
so I just go with my plan 93 so he'll
take all right and I'll take all right
now it's his move rook to d8 all right
so there's a lot of options here now so
the three moves I was looking at well
the first move I was looking at was a
hope chest okay and you should never
Bank on hope chess because yeah that's
why Julia is not an expert yet because
he loves hope just
he loves hope chess so the Hope Chest
move right now is Knight to d5 thinking
wow I'm attacking your bishop you better
move your bishop buddy you better move
your bishop and then check King here
rook takes King takes rook takes boy I
was like that's a fantasy position if
I've ever seen one
all right but can i really bank on my
opponent to make such a horrible move
you never know but there's no reason to
play Hope Chest when you have a better
position instead I calculate it out for
real because if I play Knight to d5 he
doesn't have to move this bishop he
could just move this King to f8 and
laugh at me because now my knight is in
a pen okay yeah but this is better
trust me all right so all right let's
not play Hope Chest makes sense so I
calculate up from this position I'm
going to either win I'm not going to
tell you which pawns but it's one of
three different pawns so hopefully
everybody at home can see it takes
sake sake some calculation you can PI
calculate out the five moves here but no
matter what I'm going to win upon all
right take it some time
all right so everybody in the audience
figure it out
all right look my knight is way superior
to this bishop so let's get these rooks
off okay because I don't know if this
looks better than the brook right
eek will you come over here five two
five now this is worth three and this is
worth three but I'm going to be acting
at my maximum potential while this
bishops pay up gonna be like a pawn okay
so three two one all right so I'm
crushing them alright so now I was
thinking about going Knight to d5 the
whole game right but yeah it doesn't
attack anything so Knight to f5 all
right so I'm attacking this pawn right
off the bat
Oh better move it shucks and then what
do I do
oh you're so good alright we'll forget
about that
oh you protected my pawn maybe I'll
protect it
I can't go to g7 I wish I could I wish I
could but I go to h7 okay all right all
right Knight to d6 where you get the
fork we're forking this guy and this guy
okay and there's no way you can sable
alright so so of course he's going to
play here and then you play Knight to g3
so nice to g3 h4 so black X you had two
chances to get a better position on me
if you would have just let me go ahead
with my plan
yeah
so the psych-out is a major part of
chess all right do I want double pawns
no no double pawns g4 okay so now he's
got to get something going here so he
plays b5 all right King f2 trying to get
the
now what should black play in this
position he plays the right move a five
all right should I be worried about this
probably probably but I really want this
pun
all right so if black had any sense what
move and he's got a lot of sense by the
way what moves should have be played if
in this position well you should just
try to get a queen right
b4 right so b4 let's see what the
computer says I'm crushing them all
right all right but in the in the game
he really did play the move
unfortunately c4 which allows my night
to go to d6 night on dark square attack
and the two on light and now you can
just forget about it right because it
doesn't matter I'll go get it anyway I
could play a four right now but why even
bother yeah as we learned last week in
my class but you weren't there there's
no reason in an end game because the all
these guys are your potential Queens
right all these pawns so when you know
you can win upon for free like this guy
there's no reason to trade a pawn for a
pawn right when you can just come and
get it right all right look
hello Joe we never go back see so look
there's no reason for me to ever trade a
pawn for this pawn right when I can just
do this makes sense and now you can't
even you can't even protect it free pawn
isn't that better and now I have two
potential Queens instead of one see so
you learned something today whether you
liked it or not alright alright so
that's all that's all for tonight
hopefully everybody now knows how bad
double pawns are don't give yourself
holes put a knight in your opponent's
position when there's no place for him
to kick it